president Trump told John Dickerson on
Face the Nation last week that his plan
will protect people with pre-existing
conditions the American Medical
Association says actually have a
typically make coverage completely
unaffordable we actually have will
forget about unaffordable
what's unaffordable is Obamacare John so
I'm not hearing you mr. president say
there's a guarantee of pre-existing we
actually have a we actually have a
clause that guarantees now under the
House bill states can allow insurers to
charge higher premiums to cover
pre-existing conditions states would
have to set up high-risk pools to help
those people pay for insurance
the AMA claims high-risk pools cause
Americans with pre-existing conditions
to be stuck in second-class health care
coverage if they're able to obtain
coverage at all
Nancy no was a senior adviser to Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan in the 2012
presidential campaign welcome morning so
what's going to happen now in the Senate
and what chance does this bill have well
look majority leader McConnell has
already quietly been days before once he
was in pretty close contact with speaker
Ryan during this process and once it
became clear that this bill in the house
was going to pass he already started to
assemble a group of about a dozen
Republican senators who represent all
the key committees across the political
spectrum within the republican party
from susan collins on the left to mike
lee on the right and they got to work
and i think they are it if the House
Republicans hope that the Senate
Republicans are going to pick up where
the House Republicans left off I think
that is not going to happen I think
they're basically starting from scratch
I think in the end the Senate bill will
look a lot like the House bill but there
are some big differences I think the
Senate will pass something and I think
there's gonna be enormous pressure that
on the House Republicans to pass the
Senate version the Senate version does
the GOP have momentum do you think now
and how important is momentum some
people this morning are describing it as
Trump's mission accomplished moment yeah
I look I was mixed on that Rose Garden
celebration celebration rally by
yesterday but I will say when I when I
talked to you know different members
giving the leadership they said look we
need to keep this momentum going for
seven years Republicans have Republican
politicians have been campaigning
against Obamacare it was the centerpiece
for elections 2012 10 2012 2014 2016
they've been telling their voters for 7
years we are going to do we're going to
repeal Obamacare now Republicans control
the entire federal government they want
to keep telling their own members how
are you going to look at your voters in
the eyes and say when we have the shot
to do this we didn't do this and with
each step they think the pressure
intensifies so once it passes the house
they want to make a big deal that it
passed the house one step one milestone
passed now it's up to you the Senate and
they just want to keep this momentum
going and so that's what a lot of what
yesterday's optics were about
legislating isn't easy and you have to
dole out favors in order to get things
passed there's a lot in this House bill
even though most members who voted for
it didn't read it of the twenty few
Republicans sitting in districts won by
Hillary Clinton 14 voted for this repeal
and replace are they in danger in the
midterm elections it's too early to tell
I'd make two points on this one what
many of them say is look I've got to
worry about Democrats independents
rebelling against us on what we did here
but I also have to worry about
demoralizing Republican voters in
midterm elections as you know turning
out your own voters is as important as
anything
our Republican voters think we are
incompetent we can't get anything done
when we control the entire you know the
legislative branch and the executive
branch we're doomed
so I think that is a is a big factor
here but it is an unknown dancing are
always good to have you here babies
happy Cinco de Mayo hey happy Cinco
DeMayo that your holiday thank you for
no no cancel celebrate but I'm going to
celebrate it you're right we can do full
sell it was full service celebrator got